[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous merci de nous
rejoindre sur public sénat pour votre
émission les matins du sénat aujourd'hui
si nous vous proposons de découvrir une
partie des débats en séance sur le
projet de loi pour la confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire vous allez
notamment assisté aux débats autour de
l'article 3 qui traite du secret
professionnel de l'avocat dans le cadre
des procédures pénales véritable point
de discorde entre les deux assemblées
les sénateurs ont également débattu de
l'article 7 ils réclament la poursuite
de l'expérimentation des cours criminel
départemental
quand l'état veut les généraliser je
vous laisse découvrir ces échanges
passion à l'examen de trois amendements
identiques le sens est monsieur blanc
sur le président monsieur le ministre
garde des sceaux
se tait le texte anti s'agit est
totalement inacceptable la position de
monsieur rapporteur aussi vous avez
quasiment 70 milles avocats de france
qui sont vent debout ce soir quasiment
il faut entendre quand même cette colère
nous semble-t-il 1 pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils sont vent debout parce que nous
touchons là on secret professionnel qui
est au coeur de ce métier mais au coeur
c'est son ciment son adn sa colonne
vertébrale
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous sur la
porter
c'est accessible c'est insécables c'est
inaliénables et indivisibles
c'est intouchable c'est sacré c'est
comme ça c'est une loi la loi du 31
décembre 1971 qui est qu'il dispose en
son article 60 6-5 qu'on apprend tous
quand on s'apprête à passer un oral de
déontologie et quand on touche à ça on
touche au coeur des avocats on ne
comprend rien aux avocats si on le fait
si on accepte cette faille voilà et au
delà des avocats c'est aussi une
question essentielle d'une démocratie
osons les grands mots mais nous semble
que là ils sont appropriés de quoi
s'agit-il donc ce seul article de cette
loi 2e 71 qui dispose que l'avocat qu'il
agisse dans ses fonctions de conseil ou
d'assistance mais difficile de ce secret
et ce secret s'entend comme tout ça
couvre toutes les matières du droit dans
tous les domaines d'activité de l'avocat
que l'on parle de consultation de
correspondance d'entretien ou de défense
donc j'invite vraiment la haute
assemblée
à se pencher sur ce texte qui est très
important et potentiellement grave pour
cette profession et je vous propose à
travers cet amendement si on veut
rétablir une confiance en la justice de
commencer par l'arête la rétablir envers
ses avocats
merci chers collègues 49
merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui a été proposé par notre
collègue par le sommes tous pareils
biais et que je représente ici donc le
kilo le présent amendement fait entend
supprimer comme nous l'indiqué notre
collègue blanc la motion qui vise à
écorner le principe même du secret
professionnel de l'avocat en matière de
conseil dans le cadre des enquêtes pour
la répression des délits de fraude
fiscale de corruption trafic d'influencé
le blanchiment de ces délits
l'introduction de cette année en
commission des lois être l'huile
confusion délétère et dangereuse nous
semble-t-il entre les pièces d'un
justiciable qui ne sont pas couvertes
par le secret professionnel de l'avocat
et de facto saisissable dans le cadre
des enquêtes pédales si c'est là où tu
si cela est utile à la manifestation de
la vérité et d'autre part les
consultations d'avocats les
correspondances autres avocats et
clients et les factures de l'avocat aux
clients qui sont couvertes par le secret
et ne doivent en aucun cas pouvoir être
saisi sauf si elle recèle la preuve de
la participation de l'avocat la fraction
pédales en outre véritable sanctuaire à
l'exercice même de la profession
d'avocat de secret professionnel repose
sur la garantie de deux droits
fondamentaux que sont celui de pouvoir
se confier un avocat centre est que ces
confidences ne soit utilisé contre sans
consentement un jour et ne servent de
fotball incrimination ce droit est en
corollaire à celui de ne pas
s'auto-incriminer et celui de pouvoir
recueillir les consultations juridiques
de l'avocat en toute matière sans
crainte de voir un jour ces
consultations utiliser cotrel plus
largement au portant à tête à
l'indivisibilité du secret professionnel
des avocats c'est la légitimité même de
l'état de droit qui ont affaibli en ce
qu'elle repose entre autres sur le
respect par les autorités publiques
du secret professionnel de l'avocat et
ce en toute matière enfin surtout si le
présent projet de loi affiche pour
mission de rétablir la confiance
aujourd'hui dégradée de nos concitoyens
dans la justice cette disposition vargo
de l'esprit du texte en sapant
précisément la confiance qu'ils peuvent
avoir envers les avocats et la justice
pour toutes ces raisons et afin de ne
pas créer un précédent et réversible et
dommageable plus d'un titre il convient
de supprimer cet article c'est le
fotball d'autres abonnements merci le
189e larzac
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame monsieur à les
rapporteurs chers collègues cet
amendement visait également à rétablir
la rédaction adoptée par l'assemblée
nationale qui a réaffirmé lundi
visibilité du secret professionnel de
l'avocat le secret professionnel de
l'avocat est une garantie essentielle de
notre état de droit il s'agit d'une
garantie des droits fondamentaux à la
fois pour le client est à la fois pour
l'avocat et c'est d'ailleurs une
garantie qui est protégé par le droit
européen tant en matière de la défense
que du conseil et qui dit que le secret
professionnel dit confidentialité 10
secrets de l' échange entre un avocat et
son client plus qu'un droit du client
opposable à son client le secret
professionnel est la base de la relation
de confiance entre l'avocat et son
client cette sécurité de l' échange
entre le client et son avocat c'est la
condition sinequanone d'un coup et d'un
conseil éclairé et de qualité et donc
d'une meilleure application de la règle
de droit dans la société la confiance
elle est au coeur justement de du secret
professionnel
elle est indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de notre système
judiciaire
la confiance est d'ailleurs au coeur de
ce texte puisqu'il est justement
question du projet de loi pour la
confiance dans l'institution judiciaire
je ne peux que saluer les dispositions
de ce projet de loi qui viennent
renforcer la protection du secret
professionnel de l'avocat il est
pertinent que le secret professionnel
soit étendue aux activités de conseil
afin de couvrir tout le champ de la
relation entre l'avocat et son client
al'inverse justement en raison des des
arguments qui ont été invoquées il est
vraiment difficile de concevoir que des
limites puisse être apportée en raison
de la nature des infractions dans le cas
où l'avocat n'a pas participé à la
commission des infractions poursuivies
parce que rappelons un point qui est
consensuelle le secret professionnel est
d'ores et déjà inopposable lorsque
l'avocat est soupçonné de participer à
la commission d'une infraction
aussi je crains que l'amendement de la
commission ne limitent le secret
professionnel de l'avocat ce qui ne peut
se faire qu'au préjudice du justiciable
et de la force de notre état de droit le
secret professionnel de l'avocat doit
être indivisible il doit être renforcée
c'est le sens de cet argument de cet
amendement afin de restaurer le secret
professionnel de l'avocat pour toutes
les activités professionnelles tant dans
la défense que dans le conseil je vous
remercie merci chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur
personne ne discute le secret
professionnel de l'avocat pour la
défense des libertés vous m'avez pas
vous m'avez parlé de l'époux nous avait
parlé de l'état de droit si
effectivement comme vous le pensez cher
collègue monsieur blon
la loi de 1971 doit être interprétée
comme le fait que l'avocat disposant
secret professionnel absolu et
indivisible il n'y a pas besoin d'être
réunis ce soir on n'a pas besoin de
légiférer si c'est la situation que vous
nous décrivez si ma chère collègue comme
vous venez de l'indiquer
la cdh où la cgu où les deux pourrait
trancher dans le sens que vous mmes
évoqué au regard de la primauté du droit
européen
il y aurait pas matière à se réunir le
droit français aurait été mis en
conformité
la situation est aujourd'hui
n'est pas celle que vous avez décrit
seul et très vite que là-dessus cour de
cassation 24 novembre 2001 le secret
professionnel est limité aux droits
libertés
cdh 6 décembre 2012 cgu 18 mai 1982 ça a
été très très vite dans les questions de
concurrence et le conseil
constitutionnel a eu a effectivement
tranché et décidé le 24 juillet 2015
qu'aucune disposition constitutionnelle
ne consacrons droit au secret des
échanges et correspondances des avocats
on doit encore une fois les droits de la
défense ce qui veut dire et c'est le
premier point sur lequel je voudrais
insister
le texte issu de la commission des lois
n'est pas un texte qui réduit le secret
professionnel des avocats c'est un texte
qu'il étende cette île n'étant pas de
manière illimitée mais il les camps si
vous me dites non il n'y a pas besoin de
légiférer encore une fois pourquoi y
aurait-il un article un article droite
deuxièmement sur la notion de
ce prêt illimité fou absolue
je vous l'indiquais il n'y a pas
d'autres exemples même sur des éléments
qui encore une fois tout chà nantis
comme pour le secret professionnel des
médecins et je pourrai vous faire la
liste des dérogations qui existe
toujours ce que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure les deux principes
constitutionnels les droits de la
défense et la prévention de l'ordre
public et des attentes liées aux
infractions et pour les médecins
c'est la balance avec nous ce rapport de
l'ondh dans le micro excusez moi et pour
les médecins c'est la balance avec les
règles de salubrité publique
deuxième observation
est ce que le sujet que dans le var est
simplement sujet de principe est ce
qu'ils se situent uniquement au niveau
des idées
qu'on je n'aurais pas aller trop sur des
dossiers en tant que tel mais entendre
et en tout cas chers collègues
que notre sujet
pose aussi au delà des 70 avocats dont
je connais bien effectivement comme vous
la pensée l'action etc pensez aussi que
dans notre société il y à des enquêteurs
il y à des juges d'instruction
il y à des associations qui ont une
action contre la lutte contre la
pauvreté ou la lutte contre la
corruption etc et nos travaux sont
effectivement aussi regarder de ce côté
là est ce que le sujet du secret
professionnel étendu au conseil
représente ou non une difficulté la
réponse est clairement oui si
effectivement vous donner une
une une extension il limitait au secret
professionnel là où nous proposons
simplement de l'étendre
vous ne permettez pas à notre société de
lutter correctement contre la corruption
ou la fraude fiscale je prendrai deux
exemples et je voudrais éviter de
rentrer dans toute comparaison qui
pourrait vous conduire à évoquer il se
dirait que ou aux actes il essaie de
raisonner sur l'aspect théorique
si vous êtes sur un sujet de corruption
qu'elle soit nationale ou internationale
si vous avez des questions de
rétrocommissions vous avez forcément une
société offshore ou des sociétés
offshore qui vont intervenir pour
récupérer du mois c'est ce que me donne
les disent les spécialistes
le mauvais ça vaut 80 ce droit privé ne
connais pas ces éléments mais vous avez
forcément une société offshore et je ne
dis pas qu'un avocat aura monté cette
société off shore je ne suis pas serein
et les zones non mais dans l'examen dans
l'est les opérations qui vont conduire à
la création de cette société dans les
mouvements bancaires qui vont intervenir
forcément à un moment donné vous aurez
l'intervention d'un avocat je n'ai
encore j'ai bien dis pas comme auteur je
ne suis pas du tout sur ce terrain mais
il visera à un moment donné les éléments
ne serait-ce qu'un compte rendu de
réunions dans le secrétariat d'une
société prenez un deuxième exemple en
matière de
fraude fiscale et creuser vous plaît
monsieur rapporteur
direct aux résidents jeunes devraient
plutôt rester mossier
à un deuxième exemple
la cause prof la première la plus
importante de fraude fiscale aujourd'hui
c'est dans les sociétés internationales
les le fait de remontés les montants
dans une dans un pays où le niveau
d'imposition est le plus fun et donc
pour cela vous êtes amené à survaloriser
je n'ai pas besoin de vous faire de
dessin les opérations qui sont réalisés
dans le pénis à pour faire en sorte que
les bénéfices sont des pib vous
comprenez bien que la société qui fait
cela et qui va donner des instructions
par un cabinet d'expertise-comptable ou
en cabinet d'audit je ne sais de
survaloriser les éléments vous comprenez
bien qu'à un moment donné il va y avoir
des discussions qu'il va y avoir un
procès verbal de réunion qu'il va y
avoir un bout de rédaction juridique
dans tout cela sans que l'avocat soit
l'auteur il n'y a pas en résumé pour les
spécialistes de l'enquète en matière de
fraude fiscale de corruption de
blanchiment de dossiers ou à un moment
donné la société besoin d'avoir un accès
et si vous prévoyez le secret
professionnel intègre et indivisible
sachez simplement que vous n'aurez plus
la possibilité de mener les enquêtes en
matière de fraude fiscale ou en matière
de corruption dans des conditions que
les enquêteurs considèrent comme
possible rendant encore possible leur
métier je terminerai en vous disant que
de regarder à plein de l'engagement
internationaux là dessus et si vous ne
voulez pas entendre ses arguments je me
permets de vous en présenter un dernier
vous serez au moins d'accord sur le fait
que
l'activité de conseil est une activité
concurrentielle pour les avocats on est
bien d'accord c'est la partie du métier
d'avocat ou les avocats sont en
concurrence avec les notaires les
visites justice etc etc et avec les
experts comptables dans la mesure où
c'est une activité accessoire c'est donc
une activité
non concurrentiel si demain vous décider
que le secret professionnel de l'avocat
est indivisible absolution est
uniquement pour cette profession comment
allez vous justifiez de l'égalité devant
la loi vous allez avoir un risque
d'inconstitutionnalité
évident puisque dans un champ alors il
faut vraiment conclure la non non non
mesure à porter non résidents j'ai donné
mon argument sur le risque
d'inconstitutionnalité j'en ai terminé
donc à vis des forages le même monsieur
le ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur
il ya un argument qui m'impressionne et
c'est le dernier
oui en même temps les deux exemples que
vous fournissez ces deux exemples dans
lequel là aucun un peu trompé la main
dans le pot de confiture
ce que s'ils créent une société offshore
dans le but 2
on a expressément prévu qu'il puisse
alors faire l'objet d'une perquisition
bien sûr parce qu'il est suspecté 2 et
il n'est pas question de dire que
l'avocat il est dans une impunité il est
un justiciable
comme un autre sauf qu'il est
dépositaire d'un secret et que de ce
point de vue il est un peu à part mais
naturellement aussi on le suspecte le
frôle absolument aucune raison de ne pas
aller voir chez lui
l'objet de sa fraude am d'envoyer déjà
ma perplexité il ya un argument que je
trouve excellente par don de lait
de le dire ainsi et puis un argument que
je trouve
enfin qu'il n'emporte pas ma conviction
pour être tout à fait pour toi monsieur
sénateurs c'est bien moins que je vous
dis alors quand on a dit ça comme dirait
l'autre on a rien dit il faut progresser
encore un peu
je veux d'abord faire remarquer
aux avocats qui sont ici si j'ai bien
compris et des avocats sénateurs à la
flamme avec laquelle ils défendent cette
leurs amendements me me laisse augurer
de ce qu ils sont avocats
d'abord on a renforcé le secret de la
défense tient quand même à le dire parce
qu'un morceau je sais qu'un morceau
avait les nappes à saveur mauvais dans
ce texte il ya ça
la difficulté qui subsistent c'est le
conseil il ya deux façons de concevoir
les choses au bon deal secret absolu
où on dit un certain nombre d'exceptions
je parle naturellement dans l'hypothèse
où l'avocat n'a pas commis de fraude
n'est pas suspecté d'avoir commis une
fraude sinon il est logé et c'est bien
logique à la même enseigne que tout le
monde alors il ya des choses que j'ai
entendu ces temps derniers qui sont
assez troublante ces singulières
dans les
lobbystes si j'ose dire des gens qui ont
dit mais voyez il suffirait que le
fraudeur adresse à tous est associé un
courrier et qu'il destine une copie de
ce courrier à l'avocat avec la mention
copie l'avocat
pour se prévaloir du secret
professionnel de ce texte pas c'est une
plaisanterie
c'est comme si les mêmes viennent dire
l'avocat reconnaît avoir tué quelqu'un
il écrit à tous les membres de sa
famille qu'il regrette le crime qu'il
vient de commettre mai
celui qui peut penser que ça s'est
couvert par le secret professionnel est
un doux plaisantin donc on va arrêter
avec ça c'est pas possible
enfin je dis ça j'ai progressé un peu
mais je suis pas au bout d'un
raisonnement bon c'est vrai qu'une
enquête est toujours plus facile
sans garantie pour les justiciables
d'ailleurs à l'époque enfin pardon
d'être caricatural moi aussi parce que
j'ai lu des choses qui le sont
franchement à l'époque où la torture
était autorisée il y avait bien plus de
veut qu'aujourd'hui évidemment si on
s'affranchit de toutes les régions on
est mille fois plus efficace et c'est
sûr que s'ils ont perquisitionné tous
les cabinets d'avocats on trouverait
sans doute beaucoup plus d'affaires bien
sûr parce que les gens ils viennent
déposer leurs secrets pas que des
secrets au péno des secrets civile aussi
enfin des secrets bon ensuite ya encore
une autre difficulté c'est qu'il ya un
texte de 71 et une jurisprudence de la
cour de cassation qui est discuté et
peut être discutable voilà où nous en
sommes
maintenant
la protection du secret professionnel
et du secret de la défense et du secret
du conseil il ya aussi ce qui vient
d'être dit sur la concurrence le secteur
concurrentiel dont conseil
je veux être cohérent avec ce que j'ai
dit à l'assemblée nationale et je donne
un génie un avis de sagesse
parce que j'entends ce que vous dites et
je souhaite c'est moche le plus le plus
sincère que dans le cadre de la navette
parlementaire on puisse enfin sur cette
question trouver le meilleur des
compromis
non vous n'y croyez pas la sénatrice
merci ministre monsieur longuet
je me suis le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux michel collègues je
soutiendrai l'amendement de jean
baptiste blanc et les amendements
d'ailleurs qui ont le même objet j'ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
l'intervention de notre rapporteur qui
est un homme convaincu et de bonne foi
depuis la loi de 1971 le monde a changé
et incontestablement la mondialisation
de l'économie
la rapidité des échanges d'informations
la rapidité des flux internationaux
la multiplication des déplacements
donne à l'ordre économique international
des capacités d'intervention qui sont
extraordinaires et en apparence
difficile à contrôler mais il ne s'est
pas rien passé entre 1971 et 2021 il ya
une directive de 2008 directive
européenne qui lutte contre le
blanchiment la corruption il financement
du terrorisme nous la connaissons bien
nous les sénateurs nous les
parlementaires parce que nous sommes
personnalité politique exposée qu'à ce
titre nous devons rendre des comptes sur
à peu près tout ce que nous avons dans
des combats dans nos affaires
personnelles publiquement les avocats
c'est la même chose car cher rapporteur
les avocats ont l'obligation absolue
dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
blanchiment et dans le cadre de la
directive de 2008 de d'apporter des
informations
et s'il y a un doute il y à une
organisation professionnelle parce
qu'elle vous la connaissez parfaitement
entre le fait de prêter serment ce qui a
une valeur symbolique extraordinairement
forte il y a peu de métier ont prêté
serment cela veut dire qu on accepte une
charge particulière la charge du secret
du client et mais la contrepartie c'est
naturellement de respecter le droit et
l'application de la directive de 2008 et
l'obligation de signaler et de ne pas
être complice d'une dinde et d'un délit
d'un délit disons de blanchiment et
c'est la raison pour laquelle
la loi 71 qui n'avait pas prévu cela a
été complété par l'application de la
directive de 2008 dans notre droit
français que la cour européenne de
justice et que la cour en plus à leurs
collègues oui oui c'est vrai il faut
conclure je vais être liés j'en suis
persuadé par des collègues parce que non
prenez pas les avocats pour des
complices de la malversation
merci la présidente a saisi
oui merci monsieur le président je crois
que ces amendements ont le mérite de
2,2 posé d'emblée
le coeur de la problématique de cet
article 3 je vais essayer d'être
relativement clair je dis bien je vais
essayer avec cet article 3 on a d'un
côté
les avocats par la voie du conseil
national et du conseil des barreaux et
de syndicats tels que le saf qui sont
favorables au texte initial du
gouvernement et puis nous avons de
l'autre côté des magistrats des
associations des organisations des
lanceurs dallaire qui sont favorables à
la réécriture proposés par nos au
rapporteur et particulièrement par
monsieur bonne car moi je voudrais dire
que les arguments des uns et des autres
sont entendent à bhl et qui ne seraient
pas responsables aujourd'hui de les
opposer
pourquoi
parce que je crois qu'il ne faut pas se
tromper de débat
le débat qui est posée c'est la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale et les autres
infractions qui sont liées à la
corruption et qui mérite selon nous
d'autres mesures plus contraignantes que
celles qui viserait à supprimer le
secret professionnel en matière de
conseil donc j'ai j'oserais dire n'ayons
pas en la matière de vision simpliste
chacune et chacun sait ici le combat qui
est le nôtre et particulièrement celui
d'éric bocquet
qui pointent régulièrement dans le débat
public la question de l'évasion fiscale
et de la fraude fiscale et je crois que
personne n'ignore enfin j'ose espérer
que personne n'ignore ici que les
banques et d'autres structures liées à
la finance accompagne des entreprises et
des particuliers pour qu'ils échappent à
l'impôt donc ce n'est pas nouveau
mais si beaucoup s'en indignent peut
aujourd'hui six attaques résolument et
car effectivement c'est à toute une
chaîne qu'il faudrait s'attaquer client
cabinet d'audit et possède donc
intermedia finances assure que d'accord
mais d'autres ont largement cessé de
rapporter dans ces milieux je sais bien
mais tout le monde veut supprimer du
temps de parole mais c'est comme ça il y
à des débats de nature politique qui
sont très importants comme celui ci et
je crois qu'en la matière sur ce sujet
il faut avoir de la volonté politique or
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de réelle
volonté politique dans notre pays pour
s'attaquer à la fraude fiscale
et je ne crois pas que ce soit les
mesures qui sont proposés ce soir qui
robichaud merci cher collègue monsieur
richard pour explication de vote unir
dans les deux minutes mais je voudrais
souligner auprès des collègues que
l'écart entre les positions sur le sujet
du secret professionnel en matière de
conseil il est de toutes façons de
baliser par la surveillance du conseil
constitutionnel c'est à dire que si nous
commettions
l'imprudence
d'affirmer dans la loi un code
l'expression d'un secret professionnel
sans limite en faveur des avocats dans
les activités non liées à la défense
le conseil constitutionnel nous
rappellerait que cette loi n'a pas fait
une balance équilibrée entre le principe
des droits de la défense d'un côté et de
l'autre le principe le bon ça s'appelle
l'obligation constitutionnelle de
recherche des infractions donc je crois
qu'il faut rester détendu et qu' il vaut
mieux que nous écrivions nous mêmes de
la façon la plus soigneuse possible la
délimitation de ce secret professionnel
en matière de conseil plus de que ce
devoir rédiger dans des conditions moins
pratique par une simple réserve du
conseil constitutionnel afin de
l'opération merci chers collègues le
rudulier oui merci monsieur le président
je vais être assez bref monsieur
rapporteur je pense que vous avez
juridiquement raison
mais
philosophiquement et politiquement tort
je vais juste vous donner une formule
qui a été employé par emile auguste
garçon que tout le monde doit connaître
pour cette salle cet hémicycle il disait
la chose suivante
le bon fonctionnement de la société
veut que le malade trouve un médecin le
plaideur un défenseur le catholique un
confesseur mais ni médecin ni
l'avocat ni le prêtre ne pourrait
accomplir leur mission
si les confidences qui leur sont faites
n'étaient pas apps assuré d'un secret un
vieux là
et vous voyez je me mets en place
d'un homme d'une femme d'une entreprise
qui ne peuvent pas s'exprimer en toute
liberté auprès de leurs avocats
s'exprimer par écrit ou encore aux
rhénans s'ils craignent que cette parole
soit
puisse être retournée contre dans une
procédure quelconque et à ce moment là
forcément le réflexe et qu'il se taise
et si leur silence
empêché de conseillers de défendre
correctement
ces personnes faute de connaître la
réalité de leur site de leur situation
voilà pourquoi je pense que
philosophiquement il faut véritablement
faire très attention à cette
indivisibilité de ce devoir est
également de ce conseil en tant que tel
de l'avocat et notamment sur son secret
absolu merci merci chers collègues la
parole à madame v rien et j'en profite
pour dire que le groupe union centriste
a demandé un scrutin public sur ces
trois amendements donc merci merci
monsieur président eh bien alors je ne
suis pas avocate et donc j'ai réfléchi
pourquoi est ce qu'il y aurait deux
façons de regarder l'action de l'avocat
dans un premier cas c'est la défense est
effectivement lorsqu'il doit défendre
quelqu'un il y à potentiel mois une
malversation il doit défendre au mieux
son client et on ne doit pas savoir ce
que se dit le client et l'avocat ça
c'est normal et c'est la défense et
c'est le droit de la défense et c'est ce
que dit la cour de cassation mais le
conseil quand vous le disiez monsieur le
ministre dans le conseil l'avocat il
doit pas mettre les doigts dans le pot
de confiture
il doit donner un conseil tout à fait
légal et donc il n'y a pas de raison
d'avoir un secret sur un conseil tout à
fait légale et c'est pour ça qu'on ne
peut pas juger de la même façon de la
défense et du conseil et c'est pour ça
que la cour de cassation a très
clairement dit la défense et tous les
documents liés à la défense on n'a pas
le droit d'y toucher mais les documents
liés au conseil on peut les regarder et
c'est pourquoi il n'y a pas que des
avocats qui font du conseil et que cela
ne sont pas soumis au secret
merci cher collègue monsieur le
président de la commission
non je suis ministre je voudrais dire
aux hôtels
l'amendement un
numéro
107 rectifié terre
que la commission des lois
nepal opposants du secret professionnel
de l'avocat
la rédaction de votre amendement met en
cause très clairement les travaux qui
ont été menés par les rapporteurs et la
commission des lois dans la rédaction
tel que vous l'avez proposées celle ci
est quasiment identique à l'amendement
ultérieure le troisième qui est rédigée
de la même manière mais qui a eu la
précaution de ne pas mettre en cause le
travail des rapporteurs et de la
commission
ceci dit
je ne suis pas d'accord avec
notre collègue jean baptiste blanc qui
affirme que le secret de l'avocat est
absolu depuis 1971
ce n'est pas la vérité
la preuve en est c'est que la cour de
cassation et dans sa chambre commerciale
et dans sa chambre criminelle n'ont pas
eu la même appréhension du secret
professionnel de l'avocat et de
l'étendue du secret professionnel de
l'avocat
puisque ces 200 français font une
distinction entre l'acte de défendre
dans une procédure où là évidemment le
secret est absolu
absolue y compris dans les conversations
dans les courriers qui sont échangées
mai
émet une réserve dans la partie
simplement conseil c'est à dire hors
procédures en procédures de quelque
nature qu'elle soit le secret
professionnel n'est pas appréhendée de
la même manière ce qui veut dire qu'au
moment où nous parlons dans le droit
positif c'est la situation juridique qui
nous régit
l'évolution ne tient qu'aux fait qu'à
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture
les députés ont élargi le secret
professionnel de façon absolue faut à
l'acte de conseil juridique
dès lors il est devenu absolue en tous
les cas s'il était voté dans les mêmes
termes par les deux assemblées
instituteur si tu n'en sommes pas là
mais nous avons indiqué clairement à la
commission que sur cet aspect là les
jours via passe aux explications données
par philippe bonnecarrère mais
simplement pour dire que nous n'avons
pas l'hymne supprimer le secret
professionnel de l'avocat il a été
élargi comme souhaité d'ailleurs par les
députés à l'assemblée nationale mais
limité sur les infractions les plus
graves que nous avons qui ont fait
l'objet d'échangés de discussions parce
que nous considérons enfin le commission
considère je suis totalement solidaire
de mme noura porter en tant président de
la commission des lois parce que nous
avons décidé qu'il fallait
impérativement pour des intérêts dans le
public ne pas permettre un secret absolu
et le dernier argument celui qui doit
porter en tous les cas qui doit nous
amener à la réflexion c'est que si tel
était le cas
nous aurions une distorsion profonde
avec les autres professions du chiffre
ou des notaires ou des huissiers qui
demain viendront demander au parlement
détendre également leur secret absolu
sauf que c'est d'abord le rôle des
avocats
voilà ce que je voulais simplement dire
alors la question est difficile mais
bien consciente la question est
difficile
j'ai lu dans la presse que le président
du conseil national des barreaux pensait
que les sénateurs l'avait poignardée
dans le dos
j'aurais préféré qu'il décroche son
téléphone et qu'il m'appelle il l'a fait
mais après ces déclarations est venu
nous sommes ici dans une assemblée où
chacun se respecte on a des opinions
différentes diversion que c'est normal
c'est la vie mais chacun se respecte et
j'attends autre chose d'une institution
représentative à laquelle j'appartiens
au j'appartenais que de tenir ce type de
propos et d'avoir aussi un regard précis
sur les arguments développés par la
commission des lois si monsieur le
président donc comme je vous le disais
j'ai été saisis d'une demandé scrutin
public par le groupe union centriste sur
les abonnements 100 740
989 je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable à vis du
gouvernement et de la sagesse va être
procédé au scrutin public sur les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement nombre de votants 341 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 220 pour
l'adoption 59 contre 161 le sénat n'a
pas adopté
passons à l'amendement à malabo fanti
dossa
le président en l'état l'article 3 ne
permet pas d'empêcher certaines dérives
observées au cours d' affaires récentes
ces fameuses et des rivaux monsieur le
garde des sceaux vous les avez
d'ailleurs régulièrement dénoncé à juste
titre lorsque vous étiez encore avocat
l'amendement que je vous propose prévoit
que les éléments collectés lors d'une
surveillance téléphonique ou
électronique ne puisse être utilisé à
d'autres fins que celles pour lesquelles
le juge des libertés et de la détention
les a autorisées vous l'aurez compris
cet amendement a pour objet de renforcer
le secret professionnel entre le client
et son avocat sans lequel le droit d les
droits de la défense ne peuvent être
correctement assurée lorsqu'un client
échanges avec son avocat
comme son médecin d'ailleurs il lui
confie ce qu'il a de plus cher son
honneur sa santé sa liberté sa dignité
si nous voulons garder le garantir à
tout citoyenne l'absence d' ingérence
des pouvoirs publics dans sa défense
nous devons préciser mieux encore les
contours du secret professionnel
collègue monsieur le rapporteur
oui c'est un avis défavorable dans ce
sens que l'article 3 tel qu'il vous est
présentée accorde des garanties
procédurales nouvelle importante peu aux
avocats en particulier sur les questions
de liaisons téléphoniques je rappelle
que la mise sur écoute tous les
réquisitions portant sur des données de
connexion devront maintenant être
autorisé par le juge des libertés de la
tension de la détention uniquement en
cas de raisons plausibles de soupçonner
que l'avocat a commis ou tenté de
commettre une infraction ce qui paraît a
priori répondre à l'hypothèse que vous
évoquiez et sans être lourd par rapport
à la partie un petit peu plus tendue de
notre débat ce soir entendez que le
texte est un texte qui comporte de
nombreuses évolutions importantes pour
la profession d'avocat on en adoptant
cet article qui n'ont pas fait de
discussions sur les conditions de
perquisition là vous me permettez de
souligner celles qui concernent les
réquisitions données de connexion de
nouveaux cas et
au-delà de l'extension du secret
professionnel nous trouverons d'autres
dispositions tout à faire par exemple
celles concernant les françaises
écritoire de l'acte d'avocat ton
défavorable mais sur la portée de la
navy monsieur le ministre
merci dont je me revois l'amendement a
avec deux avis défavorables pied pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée soit
45 monsieur bourgi gontrie
merci monsieur le président la
maintenance e45 doit être
appréciée
corrélativement avec les 122 123 car les
trois ont le même objet
cet article a été ça a été rappelé tout
à l'heure
notamment par le rapporteur étant le
mécanisme de protection du secret des
avocats
cela étant et le conseil d'état l'a
souligné un grand nombre de professions
bénéficient de régimes protecteur
notamment lorsqu il y à des intrusions
judiciaire qu'il s'agisse de perdre des
perquisitions
d'interceptions téléphoniques ou de
données de connexion téléphonique
il se trouve que à l'issue de la lecture
du projet de loi à l'assemblée nationale
un grand nombre de protections
supplémentaires ont été accordés aux
seuls avocats
concernant perquisition interceptions et
données de communication téléphonique
pourtant ces autres professions sont
concernés et ne vont donc pas profiter
de ces protections et parmi ces
professions les journalistes
nous connaissons la législation sur la
protection du secret des sources et nous
voyons ici donc une distorsion entre
l'encadrement car il ne s'agit que d'un
encadrement des procédures qui serait
prévu pour les avocats et il n'y aurait
pas le même encadrement pour les
journalistes et donc ce premier
amendement et c'est pour cela monsieur
le président que j'ai indiqué qu'il
était apprécié en cohérence avec le 122e
123 prévoit que pour les perquisitions
c'est l'objet de cet amendement pour les
interceptions et pour les données de
connexion
une protection pour les journées ils
soient donnés car sinon nous portons
atteinte
tout simplement à la protection des
sources
merci monsieur le rapporteur
c'est un sujet sensible sur lequel notre
commission a donné un avis défavorable
après si nos réflexions ce serait très
attention en tout cas une forme
d'hésitation l'argumentation présentée
par madame de la gontrie est importante
elle consiste à souligner que les
journalistes jouent dans la société au
titre de la défense des libertés un rôle
finalement très proche de celui des
avocats et qu'il y aurait donc un
parallélisme complet à faire en terme de
situation et ce parallélisme devrait
aller jusqu'à appliquer aux journalistes
les dispositions dont
nous venons de débattre
j'aurais tendance à
dire au président de la commission des
lois est-ce que vous accepteriez que
nous puissions travailler à terme sur ce
sujet sachant que cet amendement bien
sûr est arrivé tardivement ce qui est
normal et que nous n'avons pas pu
l'expertisé je n'ai pas la prétention
d'être un spécialiste droit de la presse
le droit de la presse et en droit tout
est fait autonome les dispositions
concernant les journalistes sont
multiples il y a eu de nombreuses
dispositions tendant à protéger leurs
sources il ya également de nombreuses
dispositions du conseil constitutionnel
je ne suis pas certain que calquer le
régime qu'on vient de décider pour les
avocats sur les journalistes
n'entraîne pas des imperfections
rédactionnelle et qui nous poserons à
terme d'importantes difficultés je pense
aussi que le parallèle madame de la
gontrie entre les deux
missions si je peux dire
particulièrement responsable des coûts
particulièrement importante pour donner
brassy ne peut pas être complet ne
serait ce que parce que à ma
connaissance les règles déontologiques
ne sont pas les mêmes il y a des règles
anthologique partout mais ces règles
déontologiques sont font l'objet de
normes pour la profession d'avocat font
l'objet à ma connaissance de charte
volontaire des tic pour les journalistes
et à ma connaissance également même si
on sent bien qu'il y à des embryons
autant les professions génie hier
historique et en particulier la
profession d'avocat à une structure avec
des ordres il n'y a pas d'ordre de
journalistes si vous me permettez cette
formule il y à un élément qui commence à
y ressembler avec un comité de
déontologie dont j'oublie l'acronyme qui
étend en quatre en quatre en quatre
lettres il ya un début en ce sens je ne
suis pas tout à fait certain cependant
que la profession de journaliste aurait
envie d'aller plus loin dans cette
restructuration
donc vous poser une question qui est
parfaitement légitime je suggère par
contre sous réserve de l'appréciation du
président de la commission des lois
telles puisse faire l'objet d'un travail
spécifique le besoin d' expertise
dépasse mes capacités
du moins dans un délai de l'ordre de
doigts trochon sera porteur de fait le
ministre
monsieur le président on propos qui
viennent d'être tenus par monsieur leurs
portes j'ai reçu il ya deux semaines les
représentants de la presse judiciaire
mais j'avoue évidemment que ce n'est pas
suffisant pour recevoir les syndicats de
journalistes
les patrons de presse la presse dans sa
diversité son éclectisme on n'a pas d'
expertise mal à me cécile untermaier
votre autres collègues députés à
l'assemblée nationale avait commencé son
propos en disant je suis surprise qu'ils
étaient tes son amendement qu'il est été
déclarée recevable
alors il l'est parce que c'est vrai qu'
on est sur des modifications du code de
procédure pénale mais franchement ça n'a
strictement rien à voir et que le
paisible confiance dans les institutions
judiciaires donc c'est un sujet qui est
très très important il faut
naturellement garantir aux journalistes
le secret des sources bien sûr bien sûr
dans une grande démocratie comme la
nôtre et je pense que ce n'est pas le
moment de le faire ça mérite une
expertise beaucoup plus large beaucoup
plus
précise d'ailleurs il n'y a pas eu d'
expertise du tout il n'y a pas d'étude
de l'impact donc je j'entends ce que
vous dites je rencontre ont parfaitement
le sens mais je ne peux pas accepter en
l'état que au détour d'un amendement par
dit vraiment déposer ce n'est pas un
reproche est un constat nous allions sur
des modifications de cette nature et
quand on sait je suis assez bien placé
pour le savoir puisque j'ai touché 6 6
et jeudi au sujet épineux de la haine en
ligne la susceptibilité la sensibilité à
fleur de peau des journalistes selon
leur obédience selon les journaux
auxquels il appartient etc on peut pas
se lancer dans un travail comme celui là
sans avoir préalablement
entendu l'ensemble de la profession et
c'est la raison pour laquelle à regret
madame la sénatrice je suis défavorable
à votre amendement merci monsieur bourgi
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pour venir
en appui aux explications cas à donner
ma collègue marie pierre de la gontrie
je voudrais rappeler aux orateurs qui
viennent de s'exprimer que le conseil
d'état dans la vie qu'il a rendue au
sujet de ce projet de loi indiqué que
les dispositions prévues pour les
avocats je cite paraissent à première
vue utile pour d'autres secrets protégés
par la loi comme le secret des sources
des journalistes c'est le point 13 de
l'avis du conseil d'état et je
rajouterais enfin que la défenseure des
droits préconise elle aussi dans son
avis de reprendre ces garanties pour les
journalistes tout est dit mes chers
collègues à ses dons jeu mais on voit
cet amendement soit 45 avec deux avis
défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
trois amendements identiques le 121
monsieur bourgi
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'une des
principales avancées de ce projet de loi
lors de son passage à l'assemblée
nationale ont consisté en l'adoption
d'une mesure qui vise à autoriser
explicitement dans la loi la présence de
l'avocat lors des perquisitions pénale
cette possibilité avait été supprimée
lors du passage du texte devant la
commission des lois actuellement si la
présence d'un avocat lors d'une
perquisition n'est pas interdite et que
toute personne peut demander à être
assistés par un avocat à cette occasion
aucune disposition d'ordre législatif ne
vient organiser une telle situation
aussi en pratique c'est le plus souvent
le magistrat qui est autorisé avocat
assister leur client lors des
perquisitions
celle ci est l'une des mesures les plus
coercitives et pourtant la moins encadré
du code de procédure pénale la présence
de la personne domicile de laquelle la
perquisition a lieu est requise dans
certains cas la personne retenue sera
amené à devoir fournir des
renseignements est compris au toit
incriminants dans ces conditions il
semble crucial de prévoir explicitement
dans la législation la possibilité pour
la personne perquisitionnée d'informer
son avocat si elle le demande l'avocat
interviendra bien entendu pour assister
son client pour l'éclairer lui rappeler
ses droits mais également ses devoirs
notamment celui de coopérer et la
possibilité qu'il a de faire modifier le
procès verbal s'il comporte des erreurs
ou de ne pas le signer s'il en désaccord
avec son contenu l'amendement précise
que les opérations de perquisitions pour
en débuter sans attendre la présence de
l'avocat pour ne pas entraver ou
retarder le travail des enquêteurs en
revanche l'accès de ce dernier au lieu
de perquisitions pourra lui être refusé
pour des motifs liés à la sécurité de
celui-ci de la personne chez qui il est
perquisitionné ou des personnes
participant aux opérations c'est le sens
de l'amendement que nous vous proposons
merci amendements identiques le 163
benarroch
le président cet amendement très bien
défendue par monsieur bourgi a pour
objet de rétablir la présence de
l'avocat lors de perquisitions une
mesure il a été rappelé qui a été
proposé par une large majorité de
députés et adopté lors de l'examen cias
assemblée nationale et qui a été
supprimé lors du passage dans notre
commission des lois là encore chers
collègues pour établir la confiance de
la justice il convient de permettre de
le déploiement des droits de la défense
les arguments qu'ils disent que cela
complexifie la procédure le déroulement
des enquêtes etc je pense perdre de vue
en partie l'objectif de notre système
judiciaire la présomption d'innocence y
en a tous étaient si garantie par les
droits de la défense tout au long de la
procédure
l'avocat être soit perçue comme un
élément perturbateur des enquêtes alors
qui est un rouage essentiel dans
l'équilibré des procès
merci chers collègues 214,9 m
mieux ce président c'est un amendement
identique au précédent qui viennent
d'être parfaitement défendu par mes
collègues il s'agit d'encadrer par la
loi quelque chose qui se fait dans la
pratique au gré des magistrats
il s'agit aussi par ses amendements
quelque part de sécuriser de sécuriser
les perquisitions qui peuvent constituer
une étape décisive dans une enquête
en porter
alors la question de la présence de
l'avocat en perquisition
nous n'y avons pas été
favorable il ya eu un débat assez
important quelles sont nos arguments
tout à néry bien perçu la pertinence des
observations qui viennent d'être
formulée premièrement la perquisition
est un élément de la procédure qui est
encadré
deuxièmement lorsque si à l'occasion de
cette perquisition
les choses ne se limite pas simplement à
la recherche d'un élément matériel et 6
lits à un interrogatoire de celui qui
est perquisitionné les règles de
l'audition libre ou de la garde à vue
s'applique à peine de nullité du
procès-verbal
troisièmement nous n'avons pas eu
l'occasion de vous les dire ce soir
n'est pas le crée les multiples
garanties qui figure dans le texte je
sais indiqué au tout début en préambule
lors de la discussion générale que nous
avions réalité très nombreux accords
avec le gouvernement dans ce texte parmi
ces accords
qui n'a donc pas fait débat puisque
celui ci a été actée dans texte de la
commission il y à la généralisation à la
suite d'un arrêt du conseil
constitutionnel
du droit ne pas s'auto-incriminer et au
droit de se taire et dont nous avons
remonté
leur part un amendement rapporteur dans
la commission des lois nous avons
remonté
l'obligation pour les enquêteurs de
rappeler à la partie qu'elle a le droit
de se taire et donc de ne pas
s'auto-incriminer dans le préambule du
code de procédure pénale en amont si je
puis dire ce qui veut dire que dans le
cadre d'une perquisition
la personne est informée qu'elle a le
droit de se taire et ne pas
s'auto-incriminer il nous semble donc
que les garanties sont à cet égard
suffisante et j'en terminerai en vous
disant que le travail des enquêteurs est
complexe il faut comme toujours trouver
un équilibre dans un monde idéal je
comprends parfaitement l'amendement
quand vous êtes dans une gendarmerie
dans un commissariat ou monde lagardère
il y à un débat qui peut intervenir
auquel participent l'avocat on est dans
des conditions sécurisées organisé pour
les uns et pour les autres
si lors d'une perquisition
vous pensez que quand les quêteurs
arrivent ils étaient cueillis à bras
ouverts qu'on lui dit mon cher monsieur
installez-vous dans le canapé nous avons
devises et ensemble nous allons prendre
ensemble un café en attendant mon avocat
et bien sûr nous irons visiter les
pièces avec celui ci si vous pensez que
cela se passe comme ça dans la vraie vie
on pourrait l'envisager je ne suis pas
tout à fait certain que cela se passe
comme cela dans la vraie vie et donc à
cet égard il me paraît raisonnable de
garder un équilibre à partir du moment
où vous en vente définis les garanties
et donc la garantie supplémentaire qui
concerne la possibilité de se taire il
ne nous semble pas nécessaire d'aller
plus loin et prévoir cette assistance ce
durant la perquisition si monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre mais ma
vie
pas tout à fait monsieur le président
monsieur monsieur reportons vous
exagérez un peu
parce que d'abord je voudrais vous dire
que si l'avocat n'est pas là
alors que son client l'attend avec
l'officier de police judiciaire sur le
canapé et qu'ils sont en train de
courtoisie en devises et en prenant un
café la perquisition peut commencer si
l'avocat n'est pas là
c'était une des conditions d'acceptation
de la présence de l'avocat en
perquisition elle devait ne pas avoir
pour but évidemment de retarder alors
les policiers notamment
les syndicats de policiers qui sont
exprimées lors du mode la sécurité jeu
j'avais été invité échanger avec eux
c'est enfin ce texte quand même retarde
considérablement non l'exemple que vous
avez donnée n'est pas juste puisque la
perquisition peut suivre son cours sans
avocat bhl j'ai entendu je le disais les
policiers
évidemment mais j'avais été marqué c'est
ce que j'ai dit d'ailleurs lorsque j'ai
eu l'occasion de m'exprimer un joli
texte de thierry lévy qui expliquait la
chose suivante en perquisition les
officiers de police judiciaire cherche
un pull ou couleur bleue parce que le
suspect a été vu porter d'intel pull et
si l'avocat est présent garde à vue il y
certes il ya quatre pull bleu
messi peut le faire et je voudrais que
vous voulez saisissiez car ils
constituent des éléments à décharge
ça me est ébranlée à l'époque pour ne
rien vous cacher monsieur le rapporteur
donc j'aime et un avis de sagesse et de
sagesse
comment dirais je
merci madame la sénatrice heureusement
que vous êtes là pour m'aider à finir
mes phrases et mâcha ministre dans le
jeu mais on voit ces troisièmes manteau
libyens vivent ces trois amendements
identiques 121 160 3 214 avec un avis
défavorable de la commission c'est un
avis de sagesse du gouvernement qui et
pour
[Musique]
qui et contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adopté
deux amendements discussion commune de
61 ans de madame qu'urban
défendu
merci le 122 monsieur bourgi
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
mes chers collègues cela moment 122
s'inscrit dans la même philosophie que
l'amendement 145 qui a été présentée
tout à l'heure par ma collègue marie
pierre de la gontrie il propose que
de renforcer la protection dont
bénéficient les journalistes concernant
l'accès aux données de connexion
effectivement et l'amendement qui suis
s'inscrit dans là dans le même objectif
celui de garantir les secret
professionnel et l'accès aux sources des
journalistes vous remercie et défendu
alors 123
monsieur le rapporteur
même avis que tout à l'heure puisque
nous avons déjà eu cette discussion est
favorable
sur les trois
le seul ministre même avis
[Musique]
merci donc j'ai mis aux voix
l'amendement 71 avec un double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adoptée même pas 2 % 22 mais butt
même pas de poste 23 ils ne sont pas
adoptées
donc je me revois l'article 3 qui est
pour l'article 3
pardon monsieur sûr
oui monsieur le président monsieur mise
notre groupe s'abstiendra sur cet
article 3 pour plusieurs raisons d'une
part notre attachement au secret
professionnel de l'avocat à la
confidentialité des rapports avec les
clients d'autre part parce que
nous avons présenté cet amendement sur
la présence de l'avocat dans les
perquisitions qui n'a pas été adoptée et
que nous avons considéré qu'il était
logique d'étendre ces dispositions aux
journalistes et en particulier au
respect du secret des sources des
journalistes
ceci n'a pas non plus été adopté et ce
sont les raisons pour lesquelles nous ne
pourrons pas fauté cet article 3
merci donc je le mets aux voix qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
voilà vous venez d'assister aux échanges
autour du projet de loi pour la
confiance dans l'institution judiciaire
un projet qui a été adopté par le sénat
après deux jours de travaux et plusieurs
modifications
une commission mixte paritaire doit
désormais se réunir pour chercher une
version commune avec les députés
l'information politique et parlementaire
se poursuit sur notre chaîne très bonne
journée
[Musique]
on